[Music]
hey
where is he at where is he at
whoa okay all right
welcome to this just my wife that was
messed up
wow okay i'm so sorry for swearing
first of many heart attacks i'm gonna
have this episode
oh oh my god
it's
oh my goodness jonathan majors
thank you god same person i
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
oh no
[Music]
doesn't even care it's not trying to
hide anything
the ego on gang the ego i know oh my god
all right comics accurate suit and
everything
let's get it let's get it okay on this
show
so perfect oh chefs kiss indeed chips
kisses
welcome back to new rock stars loki
episode six the season finale gave
us here at new rockstars an unfamiliar
sensation
then occasion despite the naysayers who
said that marvel would
never introduce a big bad in a disney
plush show despite those who said we
must not be
understanding the deeper themes of the
show if we thought it would be redundant
for the man behind the curtain to be
another tom hiddleston loki despite john
at the major saying he had no idea what
we were talking about despite
haters who said that our clue hunting
was mephisto gate all over again
folks i am happy to report that the
creator of the tva
is he who remains played by jonathan
majors the actor confirmed to be
kang
ah this is so exciting though we have to
acknowledge this is just
one of many kangs because this talky
talky talky finale
really just gave us more questions so no
time to run victory laps mt
wait a day
[Laughter]
this is inside marvel new rockstars loki
after show i'm eric voss my easter egg
breakdown of the episode is coming
tomorrow but here right now with me to
discuss the finale is
mt how are you feeling empty dude
i am so hyped for this kang war that's
about to go down world war kang
it's about to bang bro it's about to
bang
yeah the fat lady has sang yeah this is
sung i forced it i don't care because
i'm excited
uh what an insane finale that only
really works
because jonathan majors is so good yes
i know a lot of folks had trouble
visualizing what a kang reveal would
look like and
i i hear you like that is kind of a
weird thing to you know try to imagine
of of the comics of blue-faced weirdo
who takes all these different forms
uh in the same way that like when they
announced act of the harkness or when
someone told me that there would be a
thor movie with loki in it
i just have trouble seeing this until i
see it and you see how great these
actors are
tom hiddleston catherine hahn jonathan
majors who
all like played goofy shakespearean
roles in their acting school days
and maybe beyond and know how to have so
much fun
as these villainous characters and go
nuts with it
you know and it's it was just such a
delight to see the episode would not
have worked
had jonathan majors not made some of the
choices that he made
oh yeah he carried that entire episode
like i think like half
if not like more than half of that
episode was just in that room
of him just explaining like here's
what's going on guys like there's a
bunch of me trying to [ __ ] everything up
you know it's like everything is just
terrible like it's my fault but it's
sort of not my fault because i fixed it
yeah it's hilarious it's freaking
great jonathan killed it and like like
you said it's a testament to
you know the casting choice because
jonathan major is an amazing choice but
also
the costume design because i love that i
think he's wearing that immortus
gear yeah he didn't shy away from it yes
and i'm glad that they didn't go like
the blue face route
with me because like i feel like they're
always giving like the the actors of
color like all right here's a
here's some green paint or a different
color paper it's nice to be like all
right
this is just a black guy in charge this
is cool right
it was so great and uh it would have
taken away from his performance a little
bit
and like with this character you just
want to trust jonathan majors to just
handle it
and he did but this doesn't mean this is
the only incarnation of of
he who remains kang that we'll see like
he's such a good versatile actor he can
play a lot of different forms of this
guy
which is what makes it so exciting to
see now we're going to talk
a lot about him in this episode uh let's
quickly just start with what happened
this episode so it begins in this
cacophony of audio clips from mcu passed
it sounded like real world history as
well you had um nelson mandela eclipse
and greta tonberg
but then you also had uh the it's been a
long long time music from the end of
avengers end game
it's all blasting around us until we
zoom out we realize that we are
in uh the orbital time stream the sacred
timeline which is
as matthew mcconaughey would love a flat
circle that just
repeats in a ring uh orbiting the
citadel at the end of time
where loki and sylvia encounter well at
first terrifyingly miss minutes
yes yes christ that is like probably the
most successful marvel jump scare ever
like yeah that was a good one that was
like reminding me of like
green goblin and sam raimi spider-man
exactly whoa um now miss minutes tells
him that it is he who remains
and that he remains is going to offer
them the chance to be plugged
back into the sacred timeline together
reminding me a lot of like um the matrix
right that's kind of like
exactly this or the architect and you
know if you can imagine how
off-putting this might have been just
imagine the very dry monotonous
architects scene
that turned off a lot of people i think
it's underrated personally because i
kind of love
a talky scene but as a 13 year old i
didn't get that so
but now as an adult i'm like oh i'm fine
with it she offers them a chance to get
plugged back in the sacred timeline
together
but then they meet he who remains and
it's played by jonathan magers who
plays it wonderfully as this joyous
little scamp
he reveals that he has their whole
dialogue prescripted
he explains that he came from the 31st
century where he discovered alternate
uh realities and along with all of his
many variants they collaborated on the
tech that the tva now uses the time
doors tin pads pruning sticks reset
charges
but this led to a multiversal war so
miss minute's
animation video was actually telling the
truth about that it just wasn't the time
keepers who patched together it was
he who remains and so this variant
created the tva and the timekeepers to
prune the warring timelines down to one
peaceful sacred timeline
in order to prevent his even worse
variants from taking over
meanwhile mobius returns to the tva and
reveals to rinsleer that
they know that she actually came from a
high school in ohio in the year 2018
but then rentslayer mysteriously
disappears
to wear we'll talk about that later but
he remains offers loki and sylvie to
take over the tva and run it for
themselves willy wonka's style
but he admits at one point that he's
actually reached the end of his script
he doesn't know what's coming next
because he says the threshold has begun
the timeline has already begun to branch
and loki believes everything he's saying
at the end of the day sylvie doesn't uh
loki says let's just think about it for
a second
she's not ready to do that so they fight
it out and she kisses him
but it's really just to say shut up and
get out of this
and pushes him through a time door stabs
he who remains
but he says see you soon and
who knows what's coming next well
there's panic back in the tva where loki
finds mobius who has no idea who he is
and uh and that the timekeeper statues
have all been replaced by a statue
of he who remains and a mid-credits
singer confirms the second season which
i thought we already knew but i guess a
lot of people are like
oh my god that's what i thought dude i
was like wait a minute isn't this news
like shouldn't we get something like i
don't know a different scene but
it was totally fine i dug it i'm still
happy to see it
um so we're gonna talk about what just
happened who this version of kang
is what future versions of kang are
coming is this exactly
king and what sylvie just did to the
multiverse as we look at the titles that
you messed it up madness that's what she
did she totally messed it up she opened
up the can
of timelines that's for sure yeah
absolutely but first these are the last
few days that you're going to be able to
grab some of our loki inspired merch
over at newrockstarsmerch.com as of this
weekend a lot of it will be getting
pruned from our timeline and not coming
back
some sizes and styles are already sold
out so be sure to grab the new loki
gator polo or the brand new loki gator
sticker
uh we also have our loki out of time
shirt that i love this is my favorite of
the ones we've gotten so far
yeah we're also super variant of kang is
coming forward so you guys better get
getting oh oh he's coming nothing can
stop that guy
yep and then we're also super excited to
announce a mobius on a jet ski shirt
that we'll be releasing soon we never
got to see it on the show
yet but our favorite time keeper gets to
live his best life out on this cool new
shirt
yes um but also buying the shirt at new
rockstarsmerch.com not only supports new
rockstars but unlocks the ability to
write in uh
an additional custom shout out that will
appear at the bottom of the screen first
we got uh kristin morellis who says
gator loki needs to spin off
agree major agreed yeah him
and uh richard e grant classic loki just
needs to be a turner and hooch
and we'd all watch it it would be his
side major cosine
uh let's see lindsey and steven said is
kang going to be
a thanos level big bad love what you
guys do um
yeah it seems like that is the case but
in a very different way than thanos was
which is exciting
yes we're going to get all those kang
variants just popping in like i wonder
how much we're going to get i wonder how
much that's going to factor into ant-man
3 but
yeah we'll see we'll see uh and then
hannah kolka says i love you manscaping
pancakes happy 4th anniversary
i don't know what that means i think
it's really funny and i just want to say
manscaping pancakes out loud
so again get the latest obsession shirt
today before it is gone at
newrockstarsmerge.com
and the black widow inspired latest
obsession shirt is only going to be
around for a short time as well
along with that red ledger journal new
rockstarsmerch.com all right mt what's
our
uh big question coming out of this
finale well first question of the day
and the most major question i feel is
wait a day a minute what just happened
which version of kang did still be
killed and what impact does this have
on the mcu multiverse yes okay so
first thing first to be clear the name
kang
was never actually spoken this episode i
feel like they have purposely avoided it
for some reason
just say that say the name
say the name bart
[Laughter]
kang but he who remains is the name
given to that elderly final tva agent
who built the timekeepers in the comics
but here the show is suggesting it's
just another moniker
of the character named kang the
conqueror uh
and that this person just goes by many
names now jonathan magers was confirmed
to play kang in ant-man the was
quantomania which is coming february 17
2023
the guy is dressed just like kang slash
immortus he said he was born in the 31st
century just like nathaniel richards
kang
is in the comics he calls himself a
conqueror so
that plus all the other clues we've
pointed out over the past two months
quick refresher on kang in case you're
just joining us
he's one of the long time avengers
villains from the comics and he goes by
the names
kang or amortus pharaoh rama tut
uh nathaniel richards several others he
was born in the 31st century as
nathaniel richards a descendant of reed
richards mr fantastic of the fantastic
four
and he's just known as the master of
time travel of marvel he collects
trophies
in his kingdom called chronopolis he uh
respawns again and again as these
infinite variants and it's known as the
council of kangs or the kang dynasty
and uh he has this alternate younger
self who learns of his future as kang
and instead becomes iron lad
founder of the young avengers now the
version of the character that we meet in
this episode
might be the most benevolent kang like
the goodest good guy version of kang we
might meet
because despite his giddy apathy he did
create the tva
to maintain order and prevent all these
worst kangs from warring with each other
so by killing him
sylvia unleashed those worst kings
presumably all of which
will be played by jonathan majors in
several different mcu titles
just the first of whom appears as this
tva statue in the final shot
so uh as as fun as it was to see
jonathan majors play
this version of kang that kang is just
kind of like you know
emotionally removed and just kind of uh
gone stir crazy from his isolation
there are plenty of other versions of
this character that might be
more um uh violent more aggressive
um more cruel you know as we've seen in
the void like with all those loki's with
president loki like there's different
versions of people that are probably way
worse than you
are so like we got the best version of a
keg in this episode which is yeah kinda
crazy
so in this final shot where what version
of the tva is loki in well he returned
to
clearly a different tva than it was
before one in which kang
doesn't use timekeeper puppets he just
proudly rules over at himself with his
own enshrining statue
and you know tragically mobius and b15
don't recognize loki not even like the
god of mischief from his
infamous past they have no idea who this
person is which is really weird
and they say there are like over 63
branches forming kang apparently wants
them to keep growing
but what's kind of scary about this
being a different tva is the tva was
previously considered neutral ground
like separate from the sacred timeline
separate from the branches
and now it appears that it has been
conquered already by a new kang
and tells us that it is part of the
growing multiverse
or this could have been like you know
using our rules of time travel logic
here at new rockstars this could be like
a type one back to the future style
pocket approach to time travel and that
like now the timeline that he returns to
has been warped in some way
personally i think it is an alternate
reality tva
that loki has been transported it seems
that way because they because of the
statues mainly because like you know
it's just
a different version of that and so like
yeah i feel like that's probably just a
different
completely different dva that was remade
probably
i don't know with um the death of kang
if that was like triggering it or like i
don't know but because the universe is
just like
branching off it's like probably just
triggered a completely new tva
and and it's very weird because it means
that like tvas
are specific to a maybe that one was
specific to
he who remains sacred timeline but we
could have infinite numbers of tvas that
are specific to
all these other new timelines even the
tvas themselves
are not neutral ground it's not a home
base so everything is chaotic
um but the exciting thing is we are
officially in
a marvel multiverse i mean we already
were but now we get to see it
and it's exciting uh that ring of time
that orbited the citadel represented the
whole universe that we've known and now
that it's splintering off into branches
and that those branches are in the
tinier branches and those branches
intersect it looks like heat lining but
like blood capillaries it's so cool
things are about to get weird now we're
gonna have a loki season two that
explores this further
uh in which can we'll probably be the
villain and that's i'm thinking of a
lead right into quantum mania
so i think maybe loki's season two could
be late 2022 or early 2023 maybe the
month of january in 2023
it just leads right into it um ideally
would be sooner but i know that
but uh we the next thing on the calendar
is the animated series what if which
is going to be exploring some
interesting hypotheticals overseen by
watching the watcher
titles like shanghi hawkeye eternals
miss marvel
might not be as affected by the
multiverse but obviously doctor strange
and the multiverse of madness spider-man
no way home
and in the wasp quantum mania these all
obviously will and
kang for sure is gonna be in quantum
mania but he might cameo or get
referenced in all of those
yes especially what if like don't sleep
on what if everybody because it is a
marvel studios multiverse story so
because
we just got this information about all
these tangs we could see some kang
variants show up in what if so don't
sleep on that show
for sure um now the audio in the
beginning of this episode i'm gonna
break it down second by second to pull
everything i can get from it but it
contained clips from other movies
it might have contained some audio from
other franchises i don't know yet
i need to go back and listen to it but i
might have heard something from another
superhero movie franchise that was
non-mcu
and if that's the case this could be how
we get the fox x-men
and deadpool and fantastic four and
these other characters that used to be
other
ip oh yes that could be the logic of
that
this is definitely opening that with
especially with the boner effect
especially with uh michael waldron's
response when i interviewed him like
with the whole
boner effect variant thing it's just
like yeah this is definitely going to
open up the door for the fox x-men and
deadpool to come into the mcu so
we'll have to wait for that i want to
talk about these specific upcoming uh
titles one by one with umt first i
want to talk about wanda vision's final
scene because when wanda heard the
voices of her children that could have
been the precise moment that sylvie
broke the timeline
which could have been what allowed wanda
to hear an alternate reality where her
children were still
alive this is true because like that was
a major moment like of of the timeline
splitting it's just like yeah this is
sylvie's fault like that's probably the
exact
moment where the multiverse was like hey
we're alive mom
i'm over here bob it's like i'm over
here it's fine
multiverse is free so yeah that's a
really good observation i like it
and he talked about what if like showing
alternate kang variants i wonder how
worried uwatu the watcher will be about
kang like is that gonna be kind of in
the background of each of his uh setups
like
and when the timeline broke this way uh
captain britain uh peggy carter was uh
the super soldier instead of cap or he
was able to win
and take over to the u.n over here is
spider-man as doctor strange but over
here
kangas continues to [ __ ] up come on he's
just like watching him on the side
just another browser the king browser
it's like
but like as you pointed out in your
trailer breakdown for what if empty that
i thought was brilliant like
these don't have to be anthology stories
that are not connected at all i think
these are all going to be within the
context of what we just saw on loki
meaning that like these events in what
if aren't
going to set up future plot points in
the mcu specifically
in multiverse of madness doctor strange
the multiverse of madness so
uh my mind went here right and i'm
wondering i don't think kang is going to
be the villain
of multiverse of madness but i think the
way the universe is broken
is going to be the same way loki left it
right so i think kang is going to be
kind of in the background of all that
like he might show up as a cameo or he
might get referenced by wong as they're
pacing through the sanctum sanctorum or
something like that
um but i think specifically the way it
is broken now is the way in which
doctor strange will have to fix it oh
yeah i don't think that
kang will be much of a factor like you
said in multiverse of madness but like
he'll definitely be referenced as the
person that sort of you know as a major
factor to why everything's sort of
happening the way it is it's
doctor strange is like you know what
whatever it is what it is i'm the doctor
i heal things
we'll figure it out later um yeah but
yeah so like it will probably be like a
multiversal entity as the villain
um like a schuma gorath or um maybe a
dormammu
it's not gonna be the moment but it's
probably gonna be schuma but yeah anyway
yeah or or just wanda maximoff right the
scarlet witch
could be just an antagonist force uh and
that could be like if we do connect what
we just saw in loki to what we saw in
that one division post-credits scene all
these things could be connect and go all
the way to the top
i really hope that they actually make
wanda the actual villain of multiverse
of madness because that'll be a very
bold decision to see a hero as the
villain
um i mean after civil war anyway because
tony stark was the villain in that one
let's be real yeah
um now a lot of people are buzzing about
spider-man no way home that maybe the
reason sony has delayed releasing a
trailer for it is because they were
waiting for loki to end
i'm not so sure that is the reason why
we haven't seen a no way home trailer
yet
it might just be like sony's like we
don't we're not ready people are gonna
go see this movie anyway
we don't want them to already start to
guest plot points
like six months out um but
uh to me either way we already have
plenty of evidence that no way home is
going to be a
somewhat multiversal story with the fact
that they have alfred molina doc
and that they have jamie foxx electro
showing up in there and that doctor
strange is gonna be in the plot
something tells me that the multiverse
will be behind a lot of this but
to me this isn't any more or less
confirmation about like toby maguire or
andrew garfield or anything like that
yeah so in regards to the spider-man
trailer i have a weird feeling that sony
might release one
very soon i know that cause like i'm
thinking back to the uh the
end game and the uh the spider-man no
way home
trailer and i feel like sony was really
quick to release it sort of after
um end game sort of came out and it's
like all right you guys saw i gave it
down here's a spoiler
the kids of tony stark is dead spoiler
and all this stuff so like i think that
there might be waiting just like all
right
people get multiverse and madness they
get it's coming so now here it is i
don't know but like that's just me i'm
trying to remember
you are right in that sony did
coordinate its releases
of marketing for far from home with what
marvel was doing with endgame but the
first far from home trailer we got
was like the december before that summer
but it was right after the first in-game
trailer so like we got that and then
like a week or two later we got a far
from home trailer
so like they started to give us
information about end game and then
uh and then like i don't think we
knew that i we saw did we see memorials
for star
yeah we didn't see the memorials for
stark until after end game came out yeah
that's what sort of the trailer i was
talking about that mural trailer it's
just like
i feel like they just were waiting to
release it they wanted to release it but
they're like all right we have to wait
for end game
yeah wait for that crucial piece of mcu
lore to come out
and then we'll release it because we're
sony we really want to
have our spider-man thing to pop off
while the thing is hot while uh
you know marvel's hot so i think this
might be the point it might be the point
and i hope it's the case i hope we get
one tomorrow
um it would make this week a really
exciting week for us
lots of work to do but uh work we would
love to do um
now the only one of these titles that is
confirmed to future kang again is
ant-man the wasp quantum mania
uh and the joke i've seen going around
is that like
how the hell is scott lang gonna handle
this
which agreed exactly
yeah scott lang is a he's a loose cannon
he's
a crazy dude and like he pulled off that
entire time high so
we can't help scott out you can't count
them out
uh and i think this just tells us that
for sure this
is going to be uh in that quantum realm
city which i think really is going to be
chronopolis which is kings
looking more and more like it and i
think scott's going to encounter one
version of kang
and kind of like how he did in endgame
he's going to learn one piece of the
kang puzzle
but i don't think kang will be thwarted
or defeated
just because there are so many infinite
versions of him it's going to take a
multi-hero crossover event in order to
truly deal with the kang threat that's
what makes them such an exciting villain
in some ways even more so than thanos uh
because like thanos is
kind of terrifying in many ways but kang
is like first off we don't have to
reconceptualize the actor in a bigger
purple or form
you just get to let jonathan majors do
his thing
which i think was really again the wise
choice though
we could see scott trying to tackle all
of these kangs because like the title is
called quantum mania
so like the mania part of it could just
be like we gotta catch all these kings
it's kang's it's king city we gotta find
all these kings and like
they're just like hunting different
versions of kang that'd be a fun little
mate quantum mania thing
uh yeah but i don't know yeah i've been
trying to figure out what the word
quantomania means
at some point i theorize that that is
just the name of the city that they're
not gonna call it chronopolis it's gonna
be called quantum mania and that's just
where it's set
you know um but it's also obviously a
play on the fact that they just put
quantum in front of everything
so i bet like the word quantum is gonna
be a suffix for like half the script
i i really hope that like i have this
weird like wild theory that's probably
not gonna be true
that like after end game scott just like
i don't want to be ant-man anymore
because i saved the universe i want to
be
quantum man so like it's quantum mania
like because quantum man's increasing
that would be great that has to be a
joke in there for sure please
all right lots more questions to get to
but this summer get the most out of your
travels abroad by learning the language
of your destination with babble the
number one selling language learning app
order from restaurants or chat with the
locals like a pro
babble makes the whole process of
learning a new language addictively fun
and easy and yes thank you to babel for
sponsoring this episode off-screen
producer zach is trying to pick up some
italian ahead of an upcoming trip so you
can order all the best pasta
and he loves how easy babel makes the
learning experience babel's 15-minute
lessons make it the perfect way to learn
a new language on the go babel designs
their courses with practical real world
conversations in mind their teaching
method has been scientifically proven to
be effective
choose from 14 different languages
including spanish
french italian and german plus babel's
speech recognition technology helps you
improve your pronunciation in
accent there are so many ways to learn
with babble but you can access podcasts
games video stories and even live
classes
right now when you purchase a
three-month babble subscription you'll
get an additional three months for
free that's six months for the price of
three just go to babble.com and use the
promo code marvel
that's b-a-b-b-e-l-dot-com
code marvel for an extra three months
free we also want to thank upstart for
sponsoring this
episode so if you dread looking at your
credit card statement every month
upstart can help lift that weight off
your shoulders upstart is a fast and
easy way to pay off your debt with a
personal loan all online whether it's
paying off credit cards consolidating
high interest debt or funding personal
expenses over half a million people
have used upstart to get a simple fixed
monthly payment unlike other lenders
upstart looks at more than just your
credit score like your income your
employment history
that means they can offer smarter rates
with trusted partners with a five-minute
online rate check you can see your rate
up front for loans between one thousand
and fifty thousand dollars
you can receive funds as fast as one
business day after accepting your loan
find out how upstart can lower your
monthly payments today when you go to
upstart.com
marvel that's upstart.com marvel don't
forget to use our url to let them know
that we sent you load amounts will be
determined based on your credit income
and certain other information provided
in your loan application
go to upstart.com marvel all right back
to the episode empty wait a day a minute
what were those other trailer shots that
we never saw in the show including loki
as king of asgard the other shot where
he said glorious at the top of stark
tower
why did they leave those out was there
uh was there a reason yeah
i was waiting for those because like
this was the last episode so i was like
oh man we're probably gonna get that
little uh dope little flashback sequence
or maybe loki's gonna be transported to
that timeline where right um
maybe he he won the battle of new york i
think that those scenes were probably
going to happen during that miss minutes
uh sequence there
because she promises them like hey like
we give you whatever you want and i was
like oh this is what's gonna happen now
it's gonna happen now
it never happened so i was like they
probably cut it for just to make the
whole
sequence flow because they just hopped
into that uh
that palace and like it was super
atmospheric and like they probably
didn't want to like
wreck that atmosphere because like we
were about to get that king reveal
seconds later but what do you what do
you think happened yeah i think you're
right i think that was
part of what uh miss minutes was
offering them like that initial first
offer of like you can get plugged back
in the timeline everything you always
wanted
and i think that was the throne that
sylvia was referring to claim your
throat because he kept thinking like
what throne
is she talking about exactly like kang's
chair
it's a nice chair it's not a throne
though it's like a it's an office chair
you can get one of those
pretty yeah i think i saw that at ikea
it's a pretty ergonomically designed
um but not a throne but um maybe she's
like
you'll get your throne as if like you
can finally take a [ __ ] because this
whole episode this whole series
the guy is not she's been holding it
they just don't know even when missed
minutes
maybe maybe a little bit came out when
miss minutes popped up other than that
no threat for nothing for loki i mean
like some came out of me i'll let you
know that right now you know i had to
change but
it's possible that um maybe this was
like an offer that
when they met he who remains he made
good on it and did actually show them
um what might have been uh but either
way i think those that was gonna be like
the first offer on the table
um just kind of a temptation that uh
loki and sylvie
declined they're tempting demons yeah
i think it'd be really cool to see loki
break through that just be like i don't
want this
i got my girl right here but like it's
okay i think that it was probably a
wiser decision
just to let that seem flow because i
like the way it panned out wait a damn
minute
where did rent slayer go and what do you
think she learned from those
files that miss minutes and he remains
gave her
yeah that whole rinse layer thing i was
like what
like you just like all right see you
later for season two i'm just gonna pack
up my things and i'll see you later it's
just like
all right i guess uh and like they
teased us with the whole teacher thing
which is like
super cool um i really hope that
something comes out of there i i'm
wondering because like we do see
hunter b15 in that classroom and being
like hey
check this out this is what's going on
this is what the tva is lied to you
about
and but then we see like a different
version of b15 and
mobius at the end of the series so like
like we were talking about earlier
these have to be two different um
variants or two different um
tvas going on at the same time because i
don't think they would leave us hanging
with that uh red slayer like in the
classroom bit
because like those two um that the group
of mobius and and um
and b15 those they have to exist so like
they're
probably existing on two different
timelines there well yeah and i think
this is why it's so weird is normally
when variants all everyone who works in
the tv is a variant and
whatever timeline the timeline they were
on was pruned so this means that they're
visiting the
either the sacred timeline version of
rentslayer or that the rensselaer scene
is a variant but like rather than
her other self being pruned that i guess
not all of them be pre it's only when
yourself steps off your path and then
you get pruned and there's still some
sacred timeline version of yourself that
moves forward
that's the version they met in that that
school office which
it sounded like she might have been the
principal of that school because she
said what are you doing in my school
uh which like i don't know some teachers
have a pretty big ego today this is my
school
um but they gotta have tenure uh she's
pretty young to have tenure i would say
um what i thought was weird empty is she
had an ohio state university diploma
on the background there and i pegged her
for a michigan girl but no i'm just
kidding i think
the name on it was not rabona rinslayer
it was rebecca torment
which was really weird i maybe it wasn't
her office she really was a crazy person
get out of high school
no i think she has a different identity
and that
she was abducted by kang and kind of
given this new futuristic identity
uh in in the 31st century or something
like that no i
dubbed the ravona princess ravona
rinslayer she's like that's not my name
but okay
and her memory was wiped or something
like that yeah i think what was
she was told is that she is not rent
slayer that's not her name
though the way the teacher reacted was
like when they said judge ren slayer
like they wrote it just in a specific
way where she goes the hell are you
talking about
um what's she saying the hell you talk
about to the fact that he called her
judge or the fact that he called her
rent slayer
i think she probably has no idea what
those words even are it's like who's
judge med slayer what the heck's going
on here
so i think what we learned is that she
uh realized
that uh like i don't think she knew
until she read those files exactly who
was behind it but she probably had some
awakening moment
where she has some kind of um
need to protect he remains king that
he could be related to her or
romantically involved with her
uh although if if she was aware of this
romantic involvement
then she would not want to protect him
you know or
she would not um be as confused as she's
been
and if it were an unconsenting romantic
relationship
i don't think she would still be so
protective of him afterwards
so i don't think it's necessarily that
nature but i think it is possible that
he is a descendant of hers he could be
her son or something like that i never
really thought about that that would be
wild but like what i'm thinking here is
maybe
like we could just see the beginnings of
that rent slayer
um kang relationship because now we have
rentslayer basically like
i don't know sort of i don't know if
she's on the run but she's looking for
answers
and she's like i really like i really
want something to believe in and then
in here swoops in evil king like oh
hello witch leia
what's going on you're looking for
answers well follow me i mean i've got a
i'm a conqueror and that's i feel like
that's when we'll see that um that
dynamic
really flourish but uh uh with with kang
being a
direct descendant of rent slayer that
would be a major tweet yeah
i might be considered i might be
reaching there because i really do think
they're bringing them in to be a
descendant of uh
of you know fantastic four of um of rita
richards
but that's you know she could also be
related to that bloodline as well she
could have married in
she's not sue storm is what i'm saying
but i don't know what if we get
like a uh a variant of red slayer as sue
storm because that could be possible we
could get a whole variation i mean
at this point anything is possible but i
think that um
where she went i think she went to
another reality to find
that version of kang the conqueror and
that that's where we are at the end of
the show is that she kind of allowed him
to like said hey this is what's going on
in the other reality
that dude's about to die so here's your
chance
and then some evil or version of kang
was like all right let's do this
tinker tinker tinker tinker tinker and
then took over the tva
and then uh put her in charge of it um
again
like i kind of wish we got something
like that as the post-credits scene
because like yeah because we did get
leave we did get left hanging with the
whole rent slayer thing first that would
have been perfect it was like oh hey
kang nice to meet you type of deal well
here's a question probably to me one of
the most fascinating questions
wait a day a minute why was there a
fourth broken time keeper statue in the
city yes
bro that's exactly what i saw that i was
like oh [ __ ] are we going
that like the fourth mysterious time
keeper because in the comics there is a
time keeper that was
like thrown away like that was like sort
of exiled so i was like oh [ __ ] is this
who it is and then we got kang i was
like oh no this is way better like
forget that thing but yeah
that is very interesting why there was a
fourth one so this makes me think that
maybe in a previous in like a previous
cycle of the tva
there were four time keepers and then
like in this cycle there was only three
just to make things easier i don't know
but that was really what do you think is
the secret behind that
um i think you're onto something with
this idea of being a fourth time keeper
one who got away
the fact that it's broken uh makes me
believe that there was like one
either that um kang could not control
uh or that it is possible that this
existed before kang
and that he took it over uh i also had
that theory that kang
could have been a time keeper himself uh
and that was his origin story i i think
he is telling the truth about being born
in the 31st century and having that
whole
experimental phase um but i think
like that fourth time keeper could have
been like red slayer or something like
that like he originally
modeled the time keeper the fourth time
keeper on her uh
and then that one rebelled and that's
the one he fell in love with
uh and then and then out of heartbreak
he shattered it because he was rebuffed
oh i do like that that's that's a really
fun theory like i don't
have to look at like tearing down your
posters of a
a movie star who uh tweeted you back
something mean
thank you damn you jgl
i don't know why i chose jgl it's the
first one that pops up the rocks didn't
like my
tweets like damn you
rock statue of rock
um um yeah i mean even a rock statue you
wouldn't be able to pull down the rock
yeah it's just
it's just that cut you know it's that
cut okay um
well we have one more sponsor we want to
thank magic spoon thank you to magic
spoons for sponsoring this episode lots
of us are trying to eat better healthy
breakfast doesn't have to be boring
though magic spoon has the amazing
flavors you love but without all the bad
stuff in it magic spoon has zero grams
of sugar 13 to 14 grams of protein and
only four net grams of carbs in each
serving there's only 140 calories a
serving it's keto friendly gluten-free
grain free soy free low carb and gmo
free
order yourself a variety pack that comes
with four flavors cocoa fruity frosted
and peanut butter
get wild and mix up some cocoa and
peanut butter flavors in the same bowl
it tastes like a peanut butter cup
go to magicspoon.com marvel to grab a
variety pack and try it today
and be sure to use our promo code marvel
at checkout to save five dollars off
your order
magic spoon is so confident in their
product it's backed with a 100 happiness
guarantee
so if you don't like it for any reason
they'll refund your money no questions
asked
remember get your next delicious bowl of
guilt-free cereal at magicspoon.com
marvel and use the code marvel to save
five dollars off thank you to magic
spoon for sponsoring this episode
all right mt wait a damn minute why do
you think
kang seemed to target loki's in
particular
that is a really really great question
because that doesn't really get answered
like in this series not really i think
their answer probably has to do with the
fact that loki's are these chaotic
elements within the cosmos of the marvel
multiverse
yeah and so like you know they're just
troublemakers so like if you're trying
to
tell a specific story you want to get
the troublemakers out of the way so it's
just like all right
i want to be in charge so like you guys
are all just going to go into this
different
like separate reality or timeline or
whatever the void is
and you guys are going to be managed
while i manage the timeline so i feel
like it
it it probably has to do with that whole
chaos and order type deal but like what
do you think
is the reason for that i mean it does
seem like there's some willy wonka logic
here
right he did kind of run uh a big uh
search for a possible successor right
and i think he
found finally two loki's who work
together who are
so able to transcend the confines of
what he wants for the sacred timeline
that that tells them that they like him
are nexus beings so i think he saw
throughout all of his searching he kind
of just said this is the way it's meant
to be
it's like i've lived a million lifetimes
just trust me on this and so i wrote it
this way just because it's the way i
wanted to write it
um but i think he did write it that way
because like he sees like kind of a
a mono timeline view of all of reality
um and his ability to change things does
make him
i think a nexus being uh they didn't
call him that this episode but
i think he sees loki's as having as much
potential as he did
to have control over it uh so i think
that's why i think
loki's have an innate ability when they
link together in the right way to be
nexus beings
uh and that maybe he did consider
someone like wanda maximoff
but with loki there's something about
like
getting uh there's something about
loki's pride you know if you can appeal
to a loki's pride
or their narcissism you might be able to
win them over
uh and that way loki is similar to kang
whereas wanda is just on her own path
like she's more empathetic i would say
uh
to her children and the what made loki
uh diverge from kang's plants is in that
moment he turns to sylvia and says i
just want you to be okay
which such a well-performed line by tom
hiddleston
and it's heartbreaking that it didn't
work on sylvie maybe it did on some
level maybe
she was emotionally affected because she
was crying after she killed kang
uh i think she was left with that but
was enough to
stop her from killing him and i think
that was a huge moment of growth for
loki
it's like she said at the very beginning
her first words to him were it's not
about you
and finally he was able to prove that
that he understands not about him
he just wants someone he loves to be
okay and that's true love
if you can just let go yourself
seriously like that was such a great
moment and like you said like seeing
that
that transition from like battle of new
york loki to the loki this is like it
like i just want you to be okay
what a freaky character development
journey
like holy smokes yeah like that that was
only a couple of days for loki honestly
this is like whoa
people can change for us it's like you
know this is like sort of like this
decade journey of like
loki is as a character and for him it's
like oh my god last week i was like
super evil
killed a bunch of humans and now this
week i have a girlfriend i don't know
what's going on there
i do yeah the whole nexus uh being idea
yeah loki's are pretty powerful as we
can we see on we saw in the last episode
episode five
they're a lot more powerful than they
think so like yeah kang was probably
he was definitely doing a willy wonka
type thing he's like hey these two these
two could do it they could probably uh
take my job because uh this
[ __ ] sucks well one final question empty
wait a damn minute
what will season two look like like
where could we see
kang next and what do you think will be
kang's end game event
in the mcu future that we're going to be
working towards
season two might look like you know
different
tvas with different kang leaders
probably
warring against each other like we'll
see like different versions of b15 just
like ah just fighting each other in this
weird multiverse war um with like each
kang as like the king of the tva sort of
that'd be really fun um but in terms of
a kang
endgame event the only thing you can
really think of is
secret wars i think we should we could
be getting like that
you know multiverse crossing over type
deal
and kang trying to to win the the new
multiverse
war um and through the secret wars so
like i feel like the most
um logical thing next is a secret wars
but what do you think
i think you're right i think that is
absolutely a title we're working towards
um no questioning that i think uh well
first off i think season two
is something that what you described i
think it's gonna be like that rick and
morty episode i think the season three
premiere where it was like the citadel
merges with the uh the federation so you
just see these two
at odds uh massive organizations that
are just like shooting each other in the
hallways it's just gonna be nasty and
crazy
um and uh i think it's gonna be another
limited series and just like explores
kang as a character i think it's gonna
be
showing his history and how he got to
where he is
um so where do i think we'll see him
next i hope we see kang before that
i assume that series will happen leading
into ant-man the wasp quantomania which
means
late 2022 early 2023 but i hope that we
get some
reference to kang in multiverse of
madness or no way home
um and like even if it's just like who
is doing this
it's like well there have been some
stories about someone named he who
remains
or he goes by many names mortis pharaoh
ramat
you know something like that or if it's
just as simple as in spider-man no way
home
like we saw in far from home that there
were new occupants of avengers tower
we had been suggesting it could have
been the baxter building the fantastic
four maybe in this case it really is
just kang enterprises
and we see q e and g at the top of that
tower and that's how that got there
dude that would be crazy but i think
kang's end game event i think first he
could be a villain to the fantastic four
um in which is a movie that is announced
that could come like at the end of 2023
or something like that we don't have a
release date yet for it or maybe 2024 i
can imagine marvel saying 4 and 24
you know but um but yeah i think it's
going to be
that at first but marvel has to be
careful they can't use kang too many
times
you know like is this i mean can they
i'd be like i feel like
yeah agreed yeah it can't be the same
version of kang it would just have to be
like a variant of him
you know like and you can see the
different versions of him um
but like if you make it all kang then
you deprive yourself of using other
marvel villains but then again they do
have like 20 different titles coming out
so i don't think they're going to be
burning the candle from both ends at all
um but yeah i think it's gonna be a
fantastic four movie first and then i
think whatever the next avengers movie
is if it is secret wars great but if
they're doing the 2015 one that was dr
doom who did it i might prefer to see
doom construct battle world there but if
it is kang i won't have too much of a
problem with it
uh but there could be just some other
kind of kang crisis
uh age of kang uh
reign of kang i don't know uh and that's
what they
they handle because i yeah i mean i
don't need to see them blasting through
time again
because we kind of saw that in end game
but if it is like the fantastic four
it would be a bit different yeah i think
that like we're we're likely to see a
kang
in a in a no way home type scenario
because like it is gonna be sort of
multiverse related i don't know to what
extent
but like we i think we could see kang
becoming like sort of like the stan lee
cameo type of person within like
different
uh multiverses like whenever we pop into
a new multiverse it's like oh
what's this version of kang up to it's
like oh i've been this i'm this
type of person and like i don't know
like we might see like a king like i
don't literally like you said like as a
ceo
in another universe like in kang
enterprises like i'm just king and like
he
maybe that's when he learns that he's um
you know this
part of a greater group of council of
gangs and like
you know uh branches off from there but
yeah yeah
we could see a kang in in a way home and
here's where i'll leave you
we have to start being on the lookout in
every mcu title uh
not just what if but starting with like
hawkeye miss marvel she-hulk moon knight
it wouldn't surprise me if we start
seeing little background details that
suggest that kang is already starting to
manipulate the timeline
whether it's just q e and g on the
background or if we see a shot of the
sphinx and moon night where it has its
nose still
you know like just little things where
it's like wait that's not history as we
know it and then we'll be able to start
piecing the clues together be like
little parts of the mcu in little ways
have already start to be manipulated to
set up the
the kang dynasty i hope they say that
kang's responsible for why
rhodey looks like don cheadle hey
fantastic all right yeah norton to
ruffalo you know
it's all kang's doing absolutely every
plot
hole well that is where we will leave
you for this episode of inside marvel
again my breakdown of the finale episode
will be on the channel tomorrow so keep
an eye out for that
but empty and i aren't going anywhere
we're going to be back next wednesday
for a loki postseason rewind
uh and then every week we're gonna be
here on wednesdays through august 11th
you know
that's when what if begins so we'll be
doing after shows for that but between
then now we'll have like
more questions biggest marvel questions
we'll be answering now
especially since we have so many of them
uh and then after what if we'll have
hawkeye and then it's marvelous
it never stops i'm really excited for
haley steinfeld because uh i
just love her as opposed to yeah me too
uh don't forget to check out our many
great loki merch options at
follow mt at mastertainment follow me at
eavos follow new rockstars subscribe to
inside marvel wherever you get your
podcast thank you for watching and we
will close with our favorite moment of
the episode
[Music]
you